This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the early 1990s, a block of European countries embarked on a pretty wild experiment. They decided to get rid of all their money and replace it with a single common currency. Today, the euro is something we take for granted, but 30 years ago, it was an extraordinary and risky idea. 12 different countries who spoke different languages with different cultures and economies, all using the same paper money. Nobody was
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在 20 世纪 90 年代初，一帮欧洲国家开启了一项相当疯狂的实验。他们决定抛弃各自的货币，用一种共同的单一货币取而代之。今天，欧元对我们来说已经是理所当然的事情，但在 30 年前，这是一个非同寻常且充满风险的想法。12个不同的国家，说不同的语言，有着不同的文化和经济，却都在使用同一种纸币。当时没有人
sure if it would work. And yet, despite the risk, there were some really good reasons to try. This is Jacob Goldstein, the author of Money, the true story of a made-up thing. Hey, Jacob. Hi, Roman. So let's talk about the euro, specifically we're going to talk about the design of the paper money, but let's start with the idea of the euro itself. Yet you can start that story with the fall of the Berlin Wall. How do you measure such an astonishing moment in history? The East German government said tonight they were going to make more openings in the
确信这行得通。然而，尽管存在风险，尝试它确实有一些非常充分的理由。我是雅各布·戈尔茨坦，《金钱：虚构之物的真实历史》一书的作者。嘿，雅各布。嗨，罗曼。那么我们来聊聊欧元，具体来说，我们要谈的是纸币的设计，但让我们先从欧元本身的这个概念说起。你可以从柏林墙的倒塌来开启这个故事。你如何衡量历史中这样一个惊人的时刻？东德政府今晚表示，他们将在
wall, at least a dozen more. Put bulldozers right through the wall so that more people could cross to the West. East Germany and West Germany had been separate countries since the end of World War II, and in 1990 Germany was about to become one country again, which was in many ways a joyous moment, you know, the fall of this repressive regime in East Germany, the reunification of families and communities. But in the post-war era, West Germany had become an economic powerhouse, and Europeans were afraid that a United Germany might be a little too strong, which, you know, they had some really grounded historical reasons to be worried about this kind of thing.
墙上开更多的缺口，至少再开十几处。直接用推土机推倒柏林墙，以便更多的人能够去往西方。自二战结束以来，东德和西德一直是两个独立的国家，而在 1990 年，德国即将重新成为一个统一的国家。在许多方面，这是一个欢欣鼓舞的时刻，你知道的，东德压迫性政权的倒塌，家庭和社区的重新团聚。但在战后时期，西德已经成为了一个经济大国，欧洲人担心一个统一的德国可能会有点过于强大，你知道的，他们有一些非常现实的历史理由来担心这种事情。
So the president of France, a Francois mid-eraan, came up with a plan. He proposed this deal with the German chancellor. He said, we will support a reunified Germany. If you, Germany, agree to give up your national currency and join with your neighbors in this new shared money.
于是法国总统弗朗索瓦·密特朗想出了一个计划。他向德国总理提出了这笔交易。他说，我们将支持一个统一的德国。如果你——德国，同意放弃你的本国货币，与你的邻国一同使用这种新的共享货币。
Basically, he wanted to put Germany in this big European bearhug. And Germany said, yes. Because who doesn't love a bearhug? Sure, especially a European bearhug. And Germany said yes. Because who doesn't love a bearhug? Sure, especially a European bearhug. And green in the euro involved all kinds of decisions. Like how do you replace all the money in the ATM machines? And what is the exchange rate
基本上，他是想给德国一个巨大的欧洲式“熊抱”。德国说，好啊。因为谁不喜欢熊抱呢？当然，尤其是欧洲式的熊抱。德国说，好啊。因为谁不喜欢熊抱呢？当然，尤其是欧洲式的熊抱。而创造欧元则涉及各种各样的决定。比如你如何更换自动取款机里的所有现金？旧货币和新货币之间的
between the old currencies and the new one? And there was this one seemingly small question that took up a lot of attention. What was the new money gonna look like? That's my favorite dilemma. It's a very hard question because paper money had been this kind of nationalistic thing, a place where a country would put pictures of their heroes and their landmarks, but the point of the euro was to transcend nationalism, to build this single unified Europe. So if you put, say, the Reichstag on the 100-year-old note and the Eiffel Tower on the 50, the French would be like, how come the Germans got the 100 and we only got the 50?
汇率又是多少？当时有一个看似很小的问题，却占据了大量的注意力。这笔新钱会是什么样子？这是我最喜欢的两难困境。这是一个非常棘手的问题，因为纸币一直是一种带有民族主义色彩的东西，是一个国家用来印上其英雄和地标图案的地方。但欧元的意义在于超越民族主义，建立一个单一统一的欧洲。因此，如果你把，比如说，国会大厦印在 100 欧元的纸币上，把埃菲尔铁塔印在 50 欧元的纸币上，法国人就会觉得，凭什么德国人上了 100 欧元的面值，而我们只有 50 欧元？
And then the Dutch would be like, at least you got the 50, we didn't get anything on any bill. So when the architects of the Euro announced a contest to design the new banknotes, they added a rule. No national heroes or national symbols or national landmarks, which doesn't leave a lot of options. Still, designers from 14 different European central banks submitted ideas, and on December 13, 1996, the head of the European Monetary Institute had a press conference to announce the winner. We wanted first to inform the heads of state and government about this choice because
然后荷兰人就会觉得，至少你们还拿到了 50 欧元的，我们什么钞票都没上去。因此，当欧元的设计者们宣布举办一场设计新纸币的竞赛时，他们加了一条规则。不得出现民族英雄、民族象征或国家地标，这可没留下多少选择余地。尽管如此，来自 14 个不同欧洲中央银行的设计师们还是提交了各自的想法。在 1996 年 12 月 13 日，欧洲货币研究所的负责人召开了一场新闻发布会来宣布获胜者。我们首先希望将这一选择告知国家元首和政府首脑，因为
this is a choice clearly of a symbolic, major symbolic significance. The winner, he said, was an Austrian banknote designer named Robert Kalina. In the Kalina design, there was no Eiffel Tower, no famous author or general or queen. Instead, Kalina chose the most inoffensive symbols imaginable. The design emphasizes three main architectural elements, windows, gateways, and bridges. The metaphors write themselves, you know, openness, connection, exactly what you want at this moment when a big chunk of Europe was joining together to use a single kind of money for the first time since the Roman
这显然是一个具有重大象征意义的选择。他说，获胜者是一位名叫罗伯特·卡利纳的奥地利纸币设计师。在卡利纳的设计中，没有埃菲尔铁塔，没有著名的作家、将军或女王。相反，卡利纳选择了可以想象到的最不会引起争议的符号。该设计强调了三个主要的建筑元素：窗户、门廊和桥梁。这些隐喻不言而喻，你知道的，开放、连接，这正是一个庞大的欧洲板块首次自罗马
Empire. And for the metaphors to work, they had to make sure these inoffensive symbols didn't represent a particular country. So the pictures on the bills weren't actual windows and gateways and bridges. They were pretend bridges, imaginary gateways. The images on the paper money were supposed to exude Europeanness, but not Spanishness or Frenchness or Germanness. Everything went fine with the windows and gateways. The problem was the bridges. The person who figured out that the problem was the bridges was a bridge-loving British journalist named Russ Swan. He was the editor of a magazine called Bridge Design and Engineering. I talked to him recently and he told me that of course he was delighted to learn that pretend bridges were going to feature prominently on Europe's new money.
帝国以来联合起来使用同一种货币时，你所渴望的东西。为了让这些隐喻发挥作用，他们必须确保这些无争议的符号不代表某个特定的国家。所以钞票上的图片并不是真正的窗户、门廊和桥梁。它们是假桥，是想象中的门廊。纸币上的图像应该散发出欧洲特色，而不是西班牙特色、法国特色或德国特色。窗户和门廊一切顺利。问题出在桥梁上。发现桥梁有问题的那个人是一位热爱桥梁的英国记者，名叫拉斯·斯旺。他是一本名为《桥梁设计与工程》杂志的编辑。我最近采访了他，他告诉我，当他得知假桥将成为欧洲新货币的显着特色时，他当然感到非常高兴。
We are the bridge people and they're using our thing for their thing. And you know, that's excellent. So Russ figured he would do a little story for his magazine about the paper money. He requested a press pack with pictures of the bills. This was the mid-90s, you know, the web was just getting going. And the euro people sent him pictures. The bridges on the bills go in chronological order. So the oldest bridges are on the smallest bills.
我们是造桥人，而他们正在用我们的东西来做他们的事。你知道的，这太棒了。所以拉斯觉得他可以为他的杂志写一篇关于纸币的小故事。他索取了一份包含钞票图片的资料包。那是 90 年代中期，你知道的，网络才刚刚兴起。欧元团队给他寄去了图片。钞票上的桥梁是按时间顺序排列的。所以最古老的桥梁在面值最小的钞票上。
It's like this little tour through architectural history. And as Russ is looking at these pictures, the first thing that catches his eye is the 500-Euro note, which is the biggest bill and the most modern bridge. The 500-year-old has a cable-stayed bridge. It's a modern-style bridge where there are these straight cables holding up most of the structure. It's graphically very striking and lovely. Again, this is supposed to be a generic example
这就像是一次建筑历史的小小巡礼。当拉斯看着这些图片时，首先映入他眼帘的是 500 欧元纸币，这是面值最大、也是最现代的桥梁。500 欧元纸币上有一座斜拉桥。这是一种现代风格的桥梁，有一些笔直的拉索支撑着大部分结构。从图形上看，它非常引人注目且精美。同样，这本应是一座桥梁的通用示例
of a bridge, not a real landmark. But Russ noticed something wrong with this supposedly fake bridge. It looked like a bridge I'd been to visit oh, six, seven weeks earlier. In northern France, it's called the Pond Normandy, the Normandy Bridge. And I thought, I think that's the Normandy,
，而不是真正的地标。但拉斯注意到这座所谓的假桥有些不对劲。它看起来像是一座我大约在六、七周前去参观过的桥。在法国北部，它被称为诺曼底大桥。我想，我认为那是诺曼底大桥，
I think that's not the fictitious structure that the European Union have said it was. So there are a lot of cable-stayed bridges and they all kind of look like this. But underneath the bridge at the sides are these pillars. And there's this one spot where you'd expect to see a pillar, but there is no pillar. And that's true for the Pond and Ormeney.
我认为那并不是欧盟所说的虚构结构。所以有很多斜拉桥，它们看起来都长这样。但是在桥下两侧有这些桥墩。有一个地方，你会期望看到一个桥墩，但却没有桥墩。诺曼底大桥确实如此。
And it's also true for this design. Russ calls up the designer of the bridge who he'd talked to for the magazine. And he winds up faxing him a picture of this 500 euro bill. And he came back to me within moments. And said, this is my bridge. This is, I recognize it. This is absolutely, positively, the bridge that I designed, the bridge that you and I stood on six weeks ago in Northern France. I will stand up in a court of law and swear on anything
这个设计也是如此。拉斯打电话给他在杂志采访过的桥梁设计师。他顺手传真了一张这张 500 欧元纸币的照片给对方。他转眼就回复了我。并说，这是我的桥。这是，我认得它。这绝对、百分之百是我设计的桥，是你和我六周前在法国北部一起站在上面的那座桥。我愿意在法庭上起誓，并以你喜欢的任何东西发誓
you like. This is my bridge because there are these features that are specific to this bridge. Now of course, this made me think I found one. I wonder if I can find some more. If you are the editor of Bridge Design and Engineering. This is your moment. So over the next couple of days, Russ looked through books and old photographs, trying to identify the supposedly fake bridges on the other Euro notes. And right away, he saw this picture of the Realtto.
。这就是我的桥，因为这些特征是这座桥所特有的。现在，这当然让我觉得我找到了一个。我想知道我能不能找到更多。如果你是《桥梁设计与工程》杂志的编辑。这就是你的高光时刻。所以在接下来的几天里，拉斯翻阅了书籍和旧照片，试图找出其他欧元纸币上那些所谓的假桥。很快，他就看到了这张里亚托桥的照片。
It's a famous and really very beautiful bridge in the middle of Venice. There's an arch below. There's a parade of shops going up one side at an angle of maybe 30 degrees and down the other side of 30 degrees. So when you look at the bridge, your eye is drawn to the superstructure to the stuff on top of the bridge, which is the walkways and the shops and so forth. Russ thought the mazenry of the Rialto bridge looked awfully familiar.
这是威尼斯市中心一座著名且非常美丽的桥梁。下面是一个拱门。有一排商店以大约 30 度的角度向上延伸到一边，再以 30 度的角度向下延伸到另一边。所以当你看着这座桥时，你的目光会被吸引到上层建筑上，也就是桥上的那些东西，比如人行道、商店等等。拉斯觉得里亚托桥的砖石结构看起来非常眼熟。
So he mentally removed the walkways and the shops and all the other stuff on top of the bridge itself. I realized that that was exactly what the bank and her designer had done. It just stripped off the top and basically did a cut and paste job onto his 50-year bank and her design. and drop onto his 50-year banknote design. So now Russ had two, the 500, is the Pont de Normandy, the 50 is the Rialto in Venice, but with the buildings removed from the top. And over the next few days, he figured out a few more.
于是他在脑海中移除了人行道、商店以及桥梁本身上方的所有其他东西。我意识到这正是银行家设计师所做的事情。他只是剥离了顶部，基本上对他的 50 欧元纸币设计进行了一次剪切粘贴。然后将其放到他的 50 欧元纸币设计上。所以现在拉斯有了两个，500 欧元是诺曼底大桥，50 欧元是威尼斯里亚托桥，但去掉了顶部的建筑物。在接下来的几天里，他又找出了几个。
The 100-Euro note was the Pont de Nuali, a rail and road bridge in Paris, the 10-Euro note is a Roman aqueduct in Segovia. And finally, there was the image on the five Euro note, the smallest bill, the oldest bridge. It was a boat bridge, so it's not really a structure that's unright, it's a series of boats with planks across them,
100 欧元的纸币是巴黎的讷伊桥，是一座铁路和公路两用桥；10 欧元纸币是塞戈维亚的罗马高架渠。最后，还有面值 5 欧元的纸币上的图像，这是面值最小的纸币，也是最古老的桥。它是一座浮桥，所以它并不是真正竖立起来的结构，而是一连串铺有木板的船只，
a very ancient way of crossing a river. This is one of my favorite choices. It's this lovely old proto bridge, more than a bridge itself. It's just a would-be bridge. Clever, right? Really clever in a really kind of low tech way. So a few days into his quest,
这是一种非常古老的过河方式。这是我最喜欢的选择之一。这是一座可爱古老的原始桥梁，与其说是一座桥，不如说它本身。它只是一座准桥。很巧妙，对吧？以一种非常低科技的方式显得非常巧妙。所以在寻找答案的几天后，
Russ found an engraving that matched the picture on that five-year-old note. And it was an engraving of an ancient structure in India. So it wasn't even a European bridge. Yeah, the bonus points, right? It's both not not real and it's not in Europe. So now, Russ had all these different bridges he'd identified. He tried to call the banknote designer, Kalina, but couldn't reach him. And he decided it was time to tell the world that these fake bridges were not fake. They were fake, fake bridges.
拉斯找到了一张与那张 5 欧元纸币上的图片相匹配的版画。那是印度一座古代建筑的版画。所以它甚至都不是一座欧洲桥梁。是的，这可是加分项，对吧？它既不是真实的，也不在欧洲。现在，拉斯找到了他辨认出的所有这些不同的桥梁。他试图打电话给纸币设计师卡利纳，但联系不上。他决定是时候向世界宣告这些假桥并非假桥了。它们是假的假桥。
So I wrote up the story for the magazine. The magazine was about to go to press. He pitched the story to the BBC's main TV news show, and they wanted to do it. So they asked me to come down to London and appear on the show that night, which was very exciting, who doesn't want to be on TV. And Russ won the man, he'll send the designs of the European Beck and expect the drawing board. We hope you are so with us now. Now this was the first one, this is the one that you spotted first of all.
于是我为杂志写了这篇报道。这杂志正准备付印。他向英国广播公司（BBC）的主流电视新闻节目推销了这个故事，他们很感兴趣。所以他们让我去伦敦，当晚出现在节目中，这非常令人兴奋，谁不想上电视呢。而拉斯·韦恩，这个人，他将欧洲纸币的设计送回了画板。我们希望你现在和我们在一起。现在这是第一张，这是你首先发现的一张。
Indeed, this is the pond normandy, which is a very well-known bridge, opened only two years ago in France. The next day my phone was ringing off the look. I got page one lead in the Wall Street Journal. It was in newspapers in Finland, in Brazil. I was briefly almost famous, and enjoyed every moment of it. It was quite fun. It was fun for Russ one, but I can't imagine it was fun for Robert Collina who designed the bells.
没错，这就是诺曼底大桥，这是一座非常著名的桥梁，两年前才在法国开通。第二天，我的电话响个不停。我在《华尔街日报》头版头条登出。它出现在芬兰、巴西的报纸上。我短暂地几乎成名了，并且享受着其中的每一刻。这挺有趣的。这对拉斯·斯旺来说很有趣，但我无法想象对设计了这些纸币的罗伯特·卡利纳来说会有多有趣。
Collina seemed to take it okay. He basically said in interviews, I thought the bridges were generic enough, but apparently not. Collina had to start all over again. His job was to turn the fake fake bridges into real fake bridges. Collina and the Europeans, they actually consulted with engineers to make sure that they were plausible fake bridges. And in fact, the bills wound up changing a lot. Like, if we look at the before and after of that 500-year-old note, you can see, on the old 500 note, there was the missing pillar. That was the dead giveaway that it was a real bridge. The new version has that pillar, and it really looks like a fake bridge. And then maybe most interesting on the five-year-old note,
卡利纳似乎把这事看得很开。他在采访中基本上说，我以为这些桥梁已经足够普通了，但显然并不是这样。卡利纳不得不从头开始。他的工作是把“假的假桥”变成“真实的假桥”。卡利纳和欧洲人实际上咨询了工程师，以确保它们是貌似合理的假桥。事实上，纸币最终发生了很大变化。比如，如果我们看看那张 500 欧元纸币的前后对比，你可以看到，在旧版 500 欧元纸币上，缺少了那个桥墩。那是它是真实桥梁的铁证。新版本有了那个桥墩，它看起来真的很像一座假桥。然后也许最有趣的是在 5 欧元的纸币上，
Kalina got rid of that boat bridge altogether and replaced it with a apparently generic Roman aqueduct. They went through all the bag-note designs, they fixed the money. But the question is, did the Euro actually achieve its high-minded ideals that it was trying to achieve? Like, did it really bring Europe together? At first, it did. At first, everybody loved the Euro. It really did feel like one Europe coming together in a common currency.
卡利纳完全取消了那座浮桥，取而代之的是一座表面上很普通的罗马高架渠。他们检查了所有的纸币设计，修复了货币的问题。但问题是，欧元真的实现了它试图达到的崇高理想吗？比如说，它真的把欧洲凝聚在一起了吗？起初，是的。起初，大家都爱欧元。它真的让人感觉像是一个欧洲通过共同货币团结在一起。
But the new money ultimately couldn't paper over the economic differences between the different countries in Europe. And that really became clear after the different countries in Europe. And that really became clear after the financial crisis of 2008. Some countries like Germany recovered fairly quickly, but other countries like Spain and Greece did not. Tonight, a country deeply divided. All week, the banks closed. Life savings locked up inside. Endless lines at ATMs. And if Spain and Greece had still had their own money at that time,
但新货币最终无法掩盖欧洲不同国家之间的经济差异。在 2008 年金融危机之后，这一点变得尤为明显。一些国家，如德国，恢复得相当快，但另一些国家，如西班牙和希腊，则没有。今晚，一个深度分裂的国家。整整一周，银行关闭。毕生积蓄被锁在里面。自动取款机前排起无尽的队伍。如果当时西班牙和希腊仍然拥有自己的货币，
they could have printed more of it. They could have increased the supply of passetas and drachmas to help their economies recover. But they'd given up that power when they joined the Euro. So their economies just got worse and worse. They wound up limping along for years. And there is a good argument that the euro itself made them worse off. Yeah, like you could make a generic European bridge for a generic
他们本可以印制更多货币。他们本可以增加比塞塔和德拉克马的供应量来帮助经济复苏。但他们在加入欧元区时放弃了这种权力。所以他们的经济状况变得越来越糟。他们勉强维持了好几年。有一个很有说服力的论点认为，欧元本身反而让他们处境更糟。是的，就像你可以为一种通用的
European currency, but you can't make an actually generic Europe. It is many countries with lots of different issues and with lots of different economies. Yeah, the dream of the euro was this kind of abstract theoretical idea of a connected Europe. But I think maybe they should have kept those original Euro designs, the ones with the pictures of real bridges, to remind themselves that Europeans don't live in some abstract Europe with pretend bridges. They cross real bridges to real countries. But there's one more twist to this real bridge fake bridge story. It comes in 2013 when a designer in the Netherlands convinced a town called Spakenysisa to build tiny replicas of the fake bridges on the Euro notes So let's recap it started with the desire to have fake European bridges
欧洲货币设计一座通用的欧洲桥梁，但你无法创造出一个真正通用的欧洲。它是由许多有着许多不同问题和许多不同经济体的国家组成的。是的，欧元的梦想是一个互联欧洲的某种抽象理论概念。但我想也许他们应该保留那些最初的欧元设计，即印有真实桥梁图片的那些设计，来提醒自己欧洲人并不是生活在某些带有假桥的抽象欧洲里。他们穿梭于通往真实国家的真实桥梁上。但这个真实桥梁与假桥的故事还有一个转折。事情发生在 2013 年，当时荷兰的一位设计师说服了一个名叫斯帕肯堡（Spijkenisse）的小镇，建造了欧元纸币上那些假桥的微型复制品。所以我们来回顾一下，它始于拥有欧洲假桥的愿望
They ended up to be real fake European bridges and then they made an effort to make them actually fake fake European bridges And now those fake European bridges are real bridges that exist in a little town outside of Rotterdam. But they're like so small, they seem like miniature golf course bridges. So even though they're real, they seem kind of fake. Yeah, they're even the colors of the Euro notes. So they're not even pretending to be real.
结果它们变成了真实的欧洲假桥，然后他们努力把它们变成真正的、假的欧洲假桥。而现在，那些假的欧洲假桥变成了真实存在的桥梁，坐落在鹿特丹郊外的一个小镇里。但它们太小了，看起来就像迷你高尔夫球场的桥梁。所以尽管它们是真实的，但它们看起来有点像假的。是的，它们甚至还带有欧元纸币的颜色。所以它们甚至没有假装自己是真实的。
Yeah, the fakes real bridges ever. Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha! More money talk with Jacob Goldstein.
是的，这是史上最真实的假桥！哈！哈！哈！哈！哈！哈！更多关于金钱的访谈，嘉宾是雅各布·戈尔茨坦。
Now to this. So we're back with Jacob Goldstein, and you authored a new book called Money, the True Story of a Made Up thing. I've read this book. I've also listened to this book and read this book. That's how much I loved this book. And so very kind. I figured, you know, while you're here, just like tell us another story about money.
接下来是这个。欢迎回来，我们请到了雅各布·戈尔茨坦，你写了一本新书叫《金钱：虚构之物的真实历史》。我读过这本书。我也听过这本书并读过这本书。这就是我有多爱这本书。你太客气了。我想，你知道的，既然你来了，那就再给我们讲一个关于金钱的故事吧。
Okay. Well, let's do another paper money story. We're here talking about paper money. And the origin of paper money is a really interesting story that to be honest, I didn't know before I was working on the book, I'd been covering money for years, but the origin of paper money was new to me. And so that story takes place in China
好的。好吧，让我们再讲一个纸币的故事。我们在这里谈论纸币。而纸币的起源是一个非常有趣的故事，老实说，在我写这本书之前我并不知道。我报道金钱很多年了，但纸币的起源对我来说还是新鲜事。所以这个故事发生在中国的
around the year 1000 AD. It happens in the province of Sichuan. And at that time in Sichuan, they were using iron coins for money. And iron is a bad thing to use for money because it's not worth very much. Right? Yeah, it's heavy. So, like, you needed a pound and a half of iron coins to buy a pound of salt. Right?
公元 1000 年左右。它发生在四川省。当时的四川，他们使用铁币作为货币。而铁是不适合用来做货币的，因为它的价值不高。对吧？是的，它很重。所以，比如，你需要一斤半的铁币才能买一斤盐。对吧？
It's like, you have to go grocery shopping with pennies or something. It's just bad. It's just bad kind of money. And so this merchant in Sichuan at some point starts saying to people, look, you leave your terrible iron money with me and I'll give you a receipt, like a claim check. Roman left a thousand iron coins at my shop.
就像，你必须带着一堆硬币去杂货店购物一样。这太糟糕了。这是一种很糟糕的货币。因此，四川的一位商人有一次开始对人们说，听着，你们把你们那糟糕的铁币留在我这儿，我会给你们一张收据，就像取物凭证一样。罗曼在我的店里存了一千枚铁币。
And you can probably see what's going to happen. Then all of a sudden, these actual banknotes, that are notes from banks, if you will, become the thing that people trade. Exactly, exactly. They turn into money. And in fact, for a really long time, until the 20th century, paper money
你大概能猜到接下来会发生什么。然后突然之间，这些真正的纸币——如果你愿意的话，也就是银行的票据——成了人们交易的东西。没错，没错。它们变成了货币。事实上，在很长一段时间里，直到 20 世纪，纸币
will be a claim check for metal, right? More often silver or gold. But this idea that what paper money is a receipt and that the thing that it is representing is silver or gold persists for a really long time. And in China, you know, it starts with these private marches. But then the government gets involved. They see that it's working well. The government takes over the business
都将是金属的兑换凭证，对吧？通常是白银或黄金。但是“纸币是一张收据，它所代表的东西是白银或黄金”这种想法持续了非常长的时间。而在中国，你知道的，它始于这些私人商人。但随后政府介入了。他们看到这行得通。政府接管了
of printing paper money, and there is this real flourishing in China around this time connected to and driven in part by the paper money. You see more trade and you see science and you see urbanization enabled in part by the increased trade. There's this whole restaurant scene springs up and you have cities of a million people in China,
印制纸币的业务，中国在这个时期迎来了真正的繁荣，这与纸币息息相关，并在很大程度上由纸币推动。你看到了更多的贸易，看到了科学，看到了在某种程度上由增加的贸易所促成的城市化。整个餐馆行业应运而生，中国出现了拥有百万人口的城市，
which is like 10X the size of European cities at that time. And this persists for hundreds of years. Eventually, they actually try money not backed by metal. Kublai Khan is running China. He says, yeah, there's still going to be paper money, but you actually cannot trade in your paper by metal. Kublai Khan is running China. He says, yeah, there's still gonna be paper money, but you actually cannot trade in your paper for metal. For bronze, it was bronze coins at that time. And it worked.
这大约是当时欧洲城市规模的 10 倍。这种情况持续了数百years。最终，他们甚至尝试了不以金属为支撑的货币。忽必烈统治着中国。他说，是的，仍然会有纸币，但实际上你不能用你的纸币去兑换金属了。忽必烈统治着中国。他说，是的，仍然会有纸币，但实际上你不能用你的纸币去兑换金属了。当时是铜币。而且这行得通。
Like they had fiat money in China, you know, hundreds of years before there was any paper money at all in the West, really remarkable. Yeah, so what happened? Let me tell you, there is a rebellion and the rebellion forces the cons out of China and there is this new dynasty, the Ming dynasty. That is basically reactionary, we would say today,
就像他们在古代中国拥有法定货币一样，你知道的，比西方出现任何纸币早了数百年，真的非常了不起。是的，那后来怎么了？让我告诉你，发生了一场叛乱，叛乱迫使蒙古人撤出了中国，并出现了新朝代，即明朝。我们今天会说，这基本上是保守倒退的，
they don't like this paper money and all of this trade and all these cities, like the ideal for the Ming dynasty rulers is the self-sufficient agricultural village. And they actually wind up getting rid of paper money. This real breakthrough that helped people live better material lives disappears. And so for a while, there is no paper money anywhere in the world anymore. There's a few hundred years where paper money is just gone from the face of the earth.
他们不喜欢这种纸币、所有的贸易和这些城市。对明朝统治者来说，理想的境界是自给自足的农业村庄。他们实际上最终废除了纸币。这种帮助人们过上更好物质生活的重要突破消失了。因此在一段时间里，世界上任何地方都没有纸币了。纸币从地球表面消失了整整几百年。
And then it appears in Europe a few hundred years later. And in fact, after they get rid of paper money in China, China gets poorer. You know, they've had this economic flourishing, and then they get rid of it, and they become worse off. Wow. You know, there's all kinds of stories and science fiction stories about lost technologies that people then rediscover, and it's the secret to having a great and bright future is this technology from old that's when rediscovered. But there was this one, and it was
然后几百年后它在欧洲出现了。事实上，在中国废除纸币之后，中国变得更穷了。你知道的，他们曾有过经济繁荣，然后废除了它，他们的处境就变差了。哇。你知道的，有各种各样的故事和科幻小说讲述了人们后来重新发现的失落技术，而拥有美好明天的秘诀就是这项被重新发现的古代技术。但这就是其中之一，它是
paper money, and we just didn't have it out of choice for a long time. That's a really nice read of it. Yeah, like in, you know, 1500,500 humanity had this amazing loss technology, right? Paper money. It had sort of helped this giant society flourish for hundreds of years and then vanished from the earth. Well, I love that story. I love the whole book. I thank you so much for being here, Jacob.
纸币，而我们在很长一段时间里由于选择而没有拥有它。这是一个非常美妙的解读。是的，就像在公元 1500、1600 年代，人类拥有了一项惊人的失落技术，对吧？纸币。它曾帮助这个庞大的社会繁荣了数百年，然后从地球上消失了。嗯，我喜欢这个故事。我喜欢整本书。非常感谢你能来，雅各布。
Oh, thanks for having me, Roman. The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of a Made Up Thing The True Story of edited by Chris Baroube, mix in tech production by Dara Hirsch, music biore director of sound Sean Riel. Daling Hall is the executive producer at Kurt Colesette is the digital director. Residine includes Vivian Leigh, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashemondon, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klassker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
哦，谢谢你邀请我，罗曼。《金钱：虚构之物的真实历史》本集由 Chris Baroube 剪辑，Dara Hirsch 参与技术制作，声音总监 Sean Riel 负责音乐。Daling Hall 是执行制作人，Kurt Colesette 是数字总监。制作团队包括 Vivian Leigh、Emmett Fitzgerald、Lashemondon、Christopher Johnson、Joe Rosenberg、Sophia Klassker 以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一员，总部目前位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。
In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99pi orc. We're on Instagram and ready to. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99pi. I'm the MCI Org. exam by guests. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于美丽繁华的。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@Roman Mars，也可以在 @99pi orc 上@本节目。我们在 Instagram 上，随时准备着。你可以在 MCI Org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99pi 的每一集往期节目。由嘉宾呈现。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。